[موسيقى]
طوق امني لقوات الطوارئ الخاصه بالعاصمه
المقدسه داخل ساحات المسجد الحرام لضبط
عمليه تدفقات البشريه للمعتمرين والمصلين
والزوار بعد تشغيل الحرم المكي بكامل
الطاقه الاستيعابيه بموسم رمضان هذا العام
سخرت رئاسه امن الدوله بمختلف قطاعاتها
كافه امكانياتها البشريه والاليه بالاضافه
الى جاهزيتها وجاهزيه جميع الوحدات ل سيوف
الرحمن هذه الخدمه التي نتشرف بها كما
تشرف بها جميع القطاعات الامنيه والخدميه
في خدمه ضيوف الرحمن اداره الحشود
وحمايتها هي المهمه الاولى لهؤلاء الرجال
الذين يقفون جنبا الى جنب لتنظيم وتفكيك
الكثافات البشريه وتقديم الخدمات
الانسانيه قوات الطوارئ الخاصه برئاسه امن
الدوله احد قطاعات رئاسه الامن الدوله
المشاركه في هذه المهمه وتقوم باداره
الحشود البشريه في الساحه الجنوبيه من
المسجد الحرام اضافه الى توفير الحمايه
الامنيه لملوك ورؤساء الدول اثناء اداء
مناسك العمره بالاضافه الى جاهزيه وحداتها
الخاصه للقيام بالمهام النوعيه وقت الحاجه
والدعم والاسناد في اي موقف او حدث يشهد
الحرم المكي منذ بدايه شهر رمضان اعدادا
ضخمه من المعتمرين والمصلين مما ضاعف
اعمال رجال الامن بمختلف القطاعات لحفظ
سلامه وامن الزائرين ومسانده القطاعات
العامله من الحرم المكي سلطان السلمي
العربيه